To promote regular sleep, there's a variety of techniques to aid better sleep
patterns. You should go to bed at the same time each night, and rise at the
same time each morning. You should sleep in a quiet and dark room that's not
too hot or too cold. You should make your bed comfortable, and use it only for
sleeping. Not other activities, such as reading, watching TV, or listening to
music, or even studying. You should remove all TVs. Computers and other gadgets
from the bedroom. At the very least, turn them off. Avoid large meals before
bedtime. Avoid caffeine, nicotine and alcohol four to six hours before bed.
Don't exercise within two hours before bedtime. Don't nap late in the
afternoon. If you can't fall asleep, get up and do something else. And make
it's relaxing. Oh, and about 30 minutes before bed, you should try to start
winding down, get into a routine.